the federal reserve is getting into
crypto they're not playing around they
see everyone else benefiting from these
digital currencies and the fed the
central bank of the united states they
want in and they want in bad they
released a 35-page discussion paper on
thursday of this week this marks the
fed's most significant action as they
dive deeper into digital assets now the
federal reserve is opening the debate
should they create a digital dollar or
should they not
the fed is not going to proceed with
creating a central bank digital currency
yet because they want support from both
the white house and congress we got a
quote here from the federal reserve they
said the introduction of a cbdc would
represent a highly significant
innovation in american money i disagree
i don't think it would be a significant
innovation because it's already been
created there's already 160 plus billion
dollars that has flowed into stable
coins we don't need the government to
create stable coins the private sector
already did it it works and it has been
adopted by the market in fact my belief
is that if the federal reserve or any of
the politicians and government
organizations were to step in and create
a central bank digital currency it would
not lead to innovation actually it would
just be a watered-down poorer version of
what has already been created instead
what it would lead to is it would lead
to massive financial surveillance but
the benefits of cbdc's according to the
federal reserve is that it ensures the
dollar remains the preeminent currency
and international financial system i do
agree with that but we don't need the
fed to do it it will increase financial
inclusion potentially it will improve
cross-border payments maybe and it will
ease the dollar's use in new technology
maybe and so ultimately there are
benefits to
the digital currencies or two stable
coins but why do they need to be central
bank digital currencies well there's
negative side effects they can drain
deposits from traditional banking they
can make runs on financial forms on
financial firms more likely oh wait you
mean it'd be easier for people to be
able to get access to their own money
privacy government could have a direct
view in individual citizens transactions
and infrastructure could be a tempting
target for hackers now ultimately my
biggest concern with central bank
digital currencies is that lack of
privacy that financial surveillance
that's drastically increased where
literally right now if a politician or a
government organization wants to see
into my bank account or john's or joe's
or anybody else they gotta go to court
they gotta get a subpoena they gotta say
hey we need to actually go and get a
warrant to be able to go in and look
inside that bank account
now of course
are the courts really that stringent
maybe not but still there is a check and
balance there is some level of
protection some level of financial
privacy but if all of a sudden everyone
was using central bank digital
currencies on a ledger that the
government controlled they could see
inside your bank account they could see
who you transacted with how much when
and they could use it for whatever
purposes they want one of the worst
fears is that this type of system would
then be the creation of a social credit
score where quite literally they could
say things like they do already say in
china you know what you're not allowed
to get on the subway you have to walk
you've been a bad boy or instead they
might say you know what you can't
actually spend your money on that item
why it's because you haven't done the
things you're supposed to do
now this isn't some crazy idea if you
think about it the government already
does this to some degree they give out
ebt cards and they tell people if you
don't use it by a certain time period
the money expires and oh by the way it's
for food but only the type of food that
we approve you can't actually use it to
buy prepared food you got to be able to
buy it at things at the grocery store
and so ultimately if the technology ends
up becoming pervasive enough do not be
surprised if the government tries to
implement very similar rules to what
they already have for certain portions
of our population on a grander scale now
the united states is behind there's now
23 central bank digital currencies that
have either been launched or are in
pilot the u.s we got a 35-page paper but
we ain't made no progress yet and
obviously the private companies have
over 160 billion dollars of capital
inflows to those stable coins in the
private market and so ultimately what i
do believe is that digitizing the us
dollar is a great idea it'll drive
accessibility and adoption of the dollar
on a global stage we should be rushing
to do this you can check the receipts
back in 2018 and 2019 i was literally on
national television saying one of the
most important things in the united
states economy right now is that we have
to digitize the dollar to get in the
hands of every single person that wants
us dollars around the world this will
extend the dominance of the u.s dollar
on the global system nobody listened and
of course i'll just keep saying the same
thing i've been saying for a long time
now but the downside is we got to make
sure that the government doesn't now get
higher degrees of financial surveillance
capabilities and i think that actually
the middle ground is just use the ones
that have already been created 160
billion dollars worth of adoption on its
way to trillions as long as nobody steps
in and screws it up